on the line Christopher Hitchens who has
been a guest at this table many times
about a piece in Vanity Fair that
actually the headline on this piece is
top Dowd Maureen Dowd's sharp pen
sparked a revolution at the New York
Times will she keep her controversial
edge as he enters the stuffy sanctum of
the papers up Edie page by Christopher
Hitchens and there is a picture of
Maureen Dowd and I must ask mr. Hitchens
why why the picture good morning run
know why the article I can't see you you
see so I know you're in better shape
this morning - any picture that you
think by the way I'll let the I'll let
you decide that right where's that
picture taken don't know there's a way
it was taken oh I know that she didn't
want to be searched about she's very shy
it was a struggle together to be to be
code act why the article you asked if I
started to ask myself questions like
that of a Monday morning I don't know
how my career would would go but well
we're interested in the media and we are
interested in obviously controversy
about it and it seemed to us that the
the occasion of Maureen becoming one of
the times is permanent commentators was
it was a good one from profile you know
her not enough to be what's called
conflict of interest but I've met her
and I described the peace I used to
Casey to have lunches with her and her
friends sort of contemporaries Jane
Mayer and Alessandra Stanley and what
what is so unusual about Maureen Dowd
that she would deserve a piece well I
mean that someone is her age she's
really quite young should have
inaugurated such a well I'm sort of
heading again the entire mission factor
I think of a service synonym for
revolution but a change in the way that
the times allows its writers to write if
you will in other words people started
to notice the byline they would it would
not be a New York Times reports emerges
it would be they'd take by this
particular author people
noticed that there was a distinctive
voice being employed that it was on the
whole disrespectful without ever being
inaccurate and thus it was an implicit
challenge to the rules of pseudo
objectivity that have governed a lot of
reportage and in fact have set the turn
so red potage in the post-war period I
think of her as a Rosalind Russell
character says a friend top and
independent and sometimes even a bit
lonely yes
I mean well this is that's the bit I
mean there to house to my piece one is
about journalism as its practiced now
and a ourian isn't exemplar of it the
other is about her as a person and
obviously I'll call as many friends as I
could find to ask their opinion or that
well there's another you know I assume
you've seen your piece but there's
another you know a head not a headline
but they a paragraph withdraw and says
her attachment to ball gowns and glory
days extravagance is well known this is
my surance don't look she wants
announced so she did she announced that
too you know that was in fact to a a
senior diplomat in Washington told me
that story but for those people that
read the New York Times and have seen
the syndicated column of now help me Ana
she's gone she laughed she stopped
writing she wants to go back writing
novels what will they get from Maureen
Dowd if they as the replacement well
what I'm hoping that they're getting
what I'm urging Maureen not sir not to
overlook is the possibility that there
would be a calmness to us who was sort
of regularly contemptuous of the sorts
of people who go into politics in this
country and for the reasons for which
they do it I say somewhere in the piece
that she once said when accused of being
unfair which a lot of people have
accused of being they were his turf you
know being judgmental not being
objective not being even-handed and so
forth when she writes about candidates
for the presidency her favorite target
being mr. Bush but also mr. Clinton her
reply was one look both of these guys
have said in effect that they will do
anything to get the top job so it seems
that they need someone writing about
them you know with a fairly sharp eye
and
very well chop and quill and that's what
I hope that's what I hope we get from
her column is is the continuous reminder
these people you know are motivated by
other things than the national interest
let's say there's the cover of Vanity
Fair and inside is Christopher Hitchens
piece on Maureen Dowd mr. Hitchens thank
you for joining us
anytime Brian have a nice day